be only on c-span - next on public lies
the education of John Dewey it's a
biography of the American philosopher
and education reformer from J Martin
this talk from Johns Hopkins University
in Baltimore Maryland is an hour and
fifteen minutes good afternoon my name
is John Irwin from the writing seminars
and it's my pleasure to introduce our
speaker this afternoon he is Professor J
Martin the Edward S Gould professor of
government and the humanities at
Claremont McKenna College and the
Claremont Graduate School during his
teaching career J Martin has been a
faculty member at Yale University the
University of California at Irvine the
University of Southern California the
University of Hawaii and at Claremont
McKenna teaching in the fields of
English American Studies and government
besides being a literary scholar and bog
referred J Martin has also been for the
last 30 years a practicing psychoanalyst
and was an assistant professor and
clinical supervisor in the department of
psychiatry and human behavior at the
University of California Irvine Medical
School for almost 20 years over his
career Martin's scholarship has been
honored with Guggenheim Rockefeller and
neh fellowships as well as numerous
other prizes for teaching and scholarly
excellence among J Martin's mini books
are his highly respected biographies of
Conrad Aiken nathaniel west's
Paul Laurence Dunbar and Henry Miller
and of course most recently of John
Dewey he is also the author of a
standard history of American literature
for the period 1865 to 1914 as well as
an important psychoanalytic text on
fictive personality at present he is at
work on a new biography of Andrew
Jackson he's also written two personal
memoirs the first winter dreams based on
a year he spent teaching in Moscow
during the 1970s and most recently
journey to a
to the to Heavenly Mountain which I have
a copy here which chronicles six months
he spent in various Buddhist monasteries
in China Jay told me today at lunch that
when he arrived at one of the
monasteries the monk said they
immediately recognized him because he
had been a Buddhist monk in a previous
life and that when he left one of the
Masters he had studied with told him he
could return to America now because he
carried Buddha in his heart on a
personal note I've known Jay Martin for
almost 15 years I met him first at the
annual Faulkner in your capital
conference in Oxford Mississippi where
our mutual interest in psychoanalytic
criticism and the writings of Faulkner
brought us in contact a contact that
we've maintained ever since due in part
to our mutual scholarly interest but do
much more at least from my point of view
to the ease charm and enthusiasm of Jays
personality the depth of his knowledge
and human understanding and the
intellectual generosity that
characterizes everything about him his
talk this afternoon is entitled
biographical and philosophical
reflections on John Dewey please join me
in welcoming Jay Martin to Johns Hopkins
thank you very much Joe and thank you
all for coming
initially the discussion of what this
lecture should be about placed it as
something that might be about Johns
Hopkins and the time that John Dewey
spent at Johns Hopkins as a graduate
student and then as I thought about it
and reflected that it it might be a
useful thing to extend beyond that and
see whether John Dewey's time here also
had a consequence for the rest of his
career and that would enable me to sort
of spread threads out across many
decades and so that's what the lecture
turned to be about
but certainly firmly rooted in Johns
Hopkins and I'm very happy to be here
in 1921 John Dewey gave a lecture course
at Columbia titled types of philosophic
thought several times during the term he
returned to a discussion of the
relations between a person's life
experience and his or her philosophic
ideas philosophy when sincere he
declared presents a personal commentary
on life it expresses the way in which
the world impinges on some personality
later he added the biographic element
must be stressed if we have to study the
motives and interests of philosophers
and later in attempting a critical
interpretation of historic philosophies
we have to pay attention to biography
and temperament and the experience of
the philosopher I follow
Dewey's lead in my talk today the title
given to it by John Irwin suits my
purpose precisely as shuttled between
biography and philosophy focusing as the
occasion amply warrants on Dewey's lived
experience as a graduate student at
Johns Hopkins and examining some
consequences of the early formative
experience for his career in philosophy
unless you have studied the sociology of
academic philosophy in America you might
not realize how audacious was John
Dewey's decision to become a professor
of philosophy his undergraduate mentor
in philosophy at the University of
Vermont a JP Tory was a clergyman
so was that University's most famous
philosopher James Marsh who had
introduced Kahn's philosophy into
America so too was almost every one of
the teachers of philosophy in American
colleges at first do we seem to think
that he could become a philosopher
simply by doing philosophy and while he
was teaching high school he sent several
articles to WT Harris's journal of
speculative philosophy but he was
mistaken of course in the context of
that time no number of articles would
lend him a job disinclined to arrive at
philosophy through teaching in theology
through training in C Allah
I do he had only two other possibilities
to study abroad where English and German
philosophers were beginning to alive
philosophy with science instead of
religion or to acquire a PhD in America
he lacked the funds to take him to
Europe and so he fastened his hopes upon
Johns Hopkins University's newly
established program in philosophy
president Gilman twice turned him down
for fellowships but Dewey persevered
borrowed tuition money was only needed
five hundred dollars at the time and was
admitted Hopkins was at least a little
like Europe were one to ask where
college life in Hopkins was scented
Dewey later remembered he would be
pointed to a little club room where
students and teachers met to drink
German beer and sing German songs more
important our spirit and leader were two
philosophers who were teaching at
Hopkins each of prepared for the clergy
at Union Theological Seminary but each
had also studied in Germany the first
george sylvester morris was the first
philosopher in america to establish a
substantial scholarly reputation through
his 1873 translation of friedrich above
eggs massive history of philosophy
Morris had studied with Herman L Ricci
at Halle and Frederick Trendelenburg in
Berlin the latter in Aristotelian and
the most prominent mediator in Europe
between empirical science and philosophy
converted to Hegelian ISM Morris at
Hopkins was bent upon defending idealism
as a science and applying Hegelian ISM
to political analysis the other teacher
was G Stanley Hall he had studied
experimental psychology with ville
homeland and cleverly anticipated that
philosophy was soon to be dramatically
influenced by psychology for him the
physiological laboratory would be the
library of philosophers and the source
borova for various reforms in education
where the school would become the
philosophic laboratory do we went to
Hopkins
with Mars and he got three permanently
important things from him a thorough
grounding in Hegel an appreciation of
science and an interest in political
analysis the last row and from Morris's
1887 book Hegel's philosophy of the
state and history these three interests
would preoccupied Dooley for the rest of
his life he idealized Mars and wanted to
be his protege while he distrusted hall
yet Hall's influence was as deep as
Morris's and it struck first in Dewey's
career in his philosophic productions
Forrest encouraged Mars encouraged
Dewey's unfortunate early disposition to
seek truth and systems Hall focused him
on facts and data as the only truths the
empiricism of particulars both teachers
planted the seed that would most stay
with Dewey that philosophy was inquiry
into all manner of things mine my quest
after certainty but the only certainty
was in the methods of philosophy and the
inquiry into truth not the arrival at it
what would come to be characteristic of
Dewey showed itself at Hopkins
he took much in very disparate matters
and whittled it slowly as he would
always do in his career seldom rejecting
any ideas but instead refining and
clarifying sometimes people said in his
style obscuring but I think not all that
came his way via by he worked out the
conflicts in his personal psychology not
surprisingly his dissertation at Hopkins
reflected and fused the differing
influences of Hall and Morris and even
margin Tory and WT Harris for that
matter its title was the psychology of
Conte and as lost as Professor Maxie
says and someone here perhaps will find
it somewhere in the Hopkins library if
now that
yes just wander around a bit looking for
something that says the psychology of
conned into you in two years at Hopkins
he finished his coursework took his
exams published five articles and
completed his dissertation we're also
taking time to study political science
with her bit backs to atoms in that
seminar debating constitutional
questions with a fellow student Woodrow
Wilson who was soon to write a book on
the Constitution do we won the debate
and in the light of present day
constitutional interpretations Woodrow
listen was wrong Dewey was right the
first fruit of his Hopkins education was
his 1886 book psychology but the other
influences also soon reached expression
Dewey psychology which preceded William
James's principles of psychology by four
years was the first scientifically
oriented work on psychology published in
America it constituted a brilliant
intellectual move on Dewey's part it's
not read at all now of course but the
originality of his work lay in the
successful fusion of philosophic
idealism with psychological experiment
to show their relation and then to
assert that philosophy must be
psychological his argument was simple
everything that exists exists in
consciousness therefore the
psychological study of consciousness is
the key to understanding all existence
psychology explored the depths of
self-consciousness and philosophy dealt
with self-consciousness that is they
were won by a neat tautology Dewey
taught his colleagues as well as its own
students the remaining of philosopher
meant becoming a psychologist in
addition in its book do we provided
scientists and philosophers with a
common language to be a true philosopher
psychologist one would speak like
neither Morris nor Hall but like John
Dewey the book proved to be an
international sensation and was soon
adopted in many colleges
I'm sure do he wrote in his introduction
that there is a way of raising
philosophic questions which can be found
more easily inside
ecology than elsewhere and is the best
possible introduction to all specific
philosophical questions couching
psychological observations in Hegelian
categories duly tautologically converted
physical perception as self
consciousness into metaphysical idealism
an idealism back into self consciousness
as the as if these were one in the same
to make his strategy work do we of
course use psychology whenever
metaphysical should have appeared during
the rest of his career every decade or
so do he freely admitted that he was
only beginning to understand and clarify
his philosophic work he did this into
his 90s or play as he liked to say so he
was soon to drop the Herculean panoply
in a psychological investigations and
move to observation when James's
principles of psychology appeared doing
characteristically dropped his own book
from his courses made James's work his
classroom text and left to Tufts and
others to teach his work this early
Dewey was ready to move forward evolving
a philosophy by way of accumulation
perhaps what Hopkins gave doing most
generally was an experience of
difference Paul and Mars were at odds
personally and philosophically yet Dewey
sword once there was no need to take
sides both could be right for him and
both could become usable therefore there
was a third teacher of philosophy at
Hopkins that due he could not take in at
first this was Charles Sanders purse at
first due he was simply bewildered by
purse nothing in his prior experience
had prepared and for this philosopher
Dewey wrote to WT Harris mr. purse
lectures on logic
but his lectures appear more strongly to
the mathematical students then to the
philosophical as we shall see however
Dewey did not dismiss purse
and he conducted a lifelong inner
occasionally external dialogue with him
until it last purse became the most
influential of his Hopkins teachers his
engagement with purse added one more
strand to do his conviction that the
philosophic enterprise requires a truly
grasping and gathering imagination his
long unresolved dialogue with prairies
kept his philosophy open and taught
Dewey to risk not to settle for the
systems his agalya nism would have
encouraged in him do his refusal to
create and consolidate any system is
part of his personality but also part of
his triumph as a thinker almost all who
knew him commented on his continuous
preoccupation with thinking his thinking
had a special cast he was interested in
postulates not absolutes in the tools of
thinking rather than in settled
convictions in learning far more than in
knowledge he said that very early he saw
quote the superficiality of all formulas
and statements which approach creeds and
he sought no disrupt disciples only
asking again quote students to use their
own minds and have their own method for
seeing things for themselves much of his
writing centers on the idea of
continuous reconstruction Ovid points
toward what he called transactional
knowing that is knowing together not in
isolation but knowing in company with
others he resembles Benjamin Franklin
and that he scarcely ever rejected ideas
with which he disagreed but always at
least considered them Dewey remarked
that when his contemporaries quote ran
across something which they didn't agree
with the one interest they displayed if
any at all was rejecting it I found by
contrast that I would wonder why an
intelligent person would hold and say
such a thing
and I decided my policy was the better
of the two his students uniformly
recorded that when they turned in papers
to him he would invariably say you've
got something here develop it he was a
true hermeneutic thinker always ready to
dispute with himself I was arguing with
myself he told the psychologist Roderick
Chisholm referring to his whole career
he kept inventing new names for what he
did because he could not accept the
complex that complex thought could be
circumscribed by
single-name do we wrote that to a
certain point he envied those who had a
single theme but for himself by contrast
I seem to be unstable chameleon-like
yielding one after another to many
diverse and even incompatible influences
struggling to assimilate something from
each and yet striving to carry it
forward pragmatism instrumentalism
functionalism operational ISM radical
empiricism idealistic empiricism
naturalistic empiricism and
transactional ism these are the changing
names he gave to what he did he did say
once he wished he had been a German and
wrote in German then he could have
combined all those together it would
have been one name for his philosophy of
pragmatism taken as a system he said as
early as 1905 I have never known a myth
to grow so rapidly as pragmatism
to read its critics one would think it
was a positive system set forth for
centuries and hundreds of volumes but I
object root and branch to the term
pragmatism perhaps Dewey's ability to
think freshly was a psychological
derivative of his personality which was
suffused with independence after he
finally freed himself to become himself
he was never again captured by either
the pole of egotism or its opposite
conformity it was always prepared for
change when I complete a book do eat old
Scudder Kleiss is launched on the sea
and its fur the fortunes concern others
I hope it will get to pour it naturally
if it doesn't I try to learn something
so I could do a better job next time it
was never content with one mode of
meaning typically he criticised Henry
Adams his comment in the education that
quote his education was the search for
some meaning and lore of life in the
world much better aim
Dewey remarked would have been to have
tried to get as many meanings and is out
of his many things as possible as he
could the lore of life is that there is
no lore no-one lore there are lasting
truths and basic principles but to last
and to remain basic they must be
always in the process of reconstruction
to his work continues to instruct us
about how to endure modernity with its
unstoppable change his respect for
experienced forces him and can teach us
to recognize the centrality of inquiry
and thus to accept the problematic
character of existence he recognized
that in individuals and no less in the
cultural community there is an almost
unconquered build read as the quote and
dislike of any change which seriously
disturbs the habits to which men are
accustomed he devoted most of his career
to confronting this hatred of change and
he can still help men and women of the
present day face change as challenge
instead of catastrophe do it
consistently stress the importance of
both intelligence and imagination not as
personal capacities but as methods of
inquiry he once said that he like Burke
zones observation that Homo sapiens is
also homo Faber he kept pondering
Bergson suggestion until a few weeks
later he improved on it I've been
amusing myself trying to see what
adjectives would most characteristically
replace sapiens in Homo sapiens Homo
fabricate or better than Bergson's homo
Faber because it includes man the make
believer the play actor the stage
performer etc people are responsible for
making their world their instruments
first for Dewey are intelligence which
aims at knowing what they are making and
second imagination which represents to
them what they can make today when
intelligence is confused with elitism an
imagination is downgraded to fantasy we
need to learn again that without those
currently despised tools no other means
of making a world will do accounts of
Dewey's teaching style provide us with
the keys into his concept of philosophy
his teaching method of course had its
origin at Hopkins since Morris went back
to the University of Michigan each
spring semester and Dewey was the only
student specializing in the history of
philosophy he was given the
undergraduate course
at Hopkins in history of philosophy I
taught that for four months from all
three of his teachers he had imbibed the
view that philosophy was thinking and he
proceeded to devise a method by which
teaching philosophy was thinking
philosophy his style of teaching have
altered over time but consistent through
the years was his emphasis on teaching
as another form of systematic and
protracted inquiry do himself did not
provide much of an account of his
teaching methods he simply taught like
most of us consistent with his
philosophy teaching was an inquiry in
which teachers and students formed a
community of minds that saw together
there was no dogmatism in this mode of
instruction as he saw it the meaning of
a class session resided in the
transaction between production usually
by the teacher at first and then
reception usually by the students
leading to production by the students
and reception by the teacher and so on
in the reflex arc one of his famous
psychological articles until the class
session or the whole course ended do we
devise different methods to achieve this
transactional inquiry at Michigan he
handed out his first job handed out
detailed syllabi and summaries of the
subjects for each class these amounted
as syllabus Amanda - usually 120 to 150
pages long outlining what he would
lecture on in each course in each class
session so that he could allow himself
and his students to think freely in the
class session itself that is he never
gave those lectures in this way he could
start anywhere and make the mode and
method of thinking his subject in any
course whatsoever one Michigan student
remembered that on the first day of a
particular class due he brought in an
alarm clock put it on the desk and said
suppose this clock is the universe and
there's something wrong inside it how
can it ever be righted this was a
semester theme and in each meaning he
gave general question for us to ponder
and at the next meeting he tried to draw
out opinion
I do not recall that he ever gave a
lecture I be Lipson who became a
distinguished attorney remembers that in
a late-afternoon class he took with Joey
the philosopher would get so wrapped up
in thinking things through that
eventually Alice his wife would send his
children Fred or Evelyn to the classroom
to open the door and shout Johnny you're
ready to go home but often he would
simply sit the children on the platform
and continue right on a student at the
University of Chicago described a later
version of Dewey's teaching style
when dr. Dooley made a speech or gave a
lecture he never stood up like an
elegant orator he acted like an ordinary
man he turned to the right leaned
sideways on the wall behind him seemed
to be looking out into the distance no
gestures no paper no notes until he
seemed to intuit that some student
wished to ask a question then he was all
eyes to that student I remember time one
time I had a question then he acted as
if he could hardly wait to hear what it
was unlike every other course of the
university she notes in Joy's class the
students did not raise their hands they
simply engaged in conversation this is
eighteen eighty six or eight 1887
decades later many students at Columbia
described Dewey's mode of teaching there
in similar terms
bland Blanchard's portrayed his manner
in the 1917 class he came shuffling into
the room looking rather absent-minded
leo at the top of his spectacles he sat
down on a chair at the rostrum looked
out of the window began crumbling a
single sheet of notepaper which usually
served as a sufficiency of notes and
began to talk he looked out of the
window and lectured on what seemed to me
after my experience of philosophers
abroad a rather mumbling fashion but I
found when I got home and went over my
notes at what seemed in the hearing
rather than consecutive and rambling
discourse was really very closely knit
and carefully thought out from the
window of the classroom which do we
frequently taught he could look out on
Rodin statue the thinker positioned
outside philosophy Hall it was an
absence in Belov what he
who was attempting to do Joe as he
looked at sort of the back side of that
statue
many students had exactly the same
experience as Blanchard the little piece
of paper he'd folded and folded and keep
talking do he's abstracted mana the talk
that seemed disjointed turning out to be
reasoned but the theme that is endlessly
reiterated in these accounts is that
Dewey's way of teaching made him
extremely vulnerable for exposed the
process of his own thoughts he wasn't
teaching he was revealing his thinking
Ernest Nagel one of my own teaches at
Columbia tells what the consequence
might be someone in the class raised a
question Julie stopped to think and
finally said I do not know the answer so
we might as well dismiss the class until
I can think through what the answer is
that is he wasn't willing this is still
Nagel to simply give a profund tree
answer and didn't think there was any
point in going on until what he thought
was a fundamental issue had been at
least reasonably resolved if there's any
hard questions after this talk I'm going
to say I let's dismiss this it's own
ethics James Guttman first his student
and later his colleague recalled I think
there was no other teacher I ever had
who gave such a sense that for 50
minutes you were watching a man think
and the symbol of this was he would take
the notes he brought along these same
old notes off and on yellow paper
sometimes on a on a brown paper bag and
crunch them up as though to say I've
thought it all through at least for now
I've said it so let me think about it
now again max Eastman says the same that
Dewey would look out of the window or up
at the ceiling and begin to talk very
slowly and with little emphases and long
pauses he was thinking rather than
lecturing but as Pro Hunter Weber said
when a student posed a question or made
a commitment as much later than the
other quotation do he came to attention
immediately he would draw out of him and
his innocent question intellectual one
destroying out was never better done
because in Dewey's act of deference he
gave
attention to anybody blancher remarks
that Dewey was a very kindly person very
generous easily approachable which had
an effect on his office conversations
with students his office always crowded
Thomas Monroe was a student at do of
Dewey's before World War one and a
colleague afterward he is a great figure
Monroe says and I hesitated to bother
him but I found him always willing to
stop what he was doing even in the midst
of typewriting
I often apologize for interrupting him
but he always waved me to a chair and
asked me to explain what I had in mind
he'd finished with some good practical
suggestion he was always friendly never
pompous he tacitly encouraged students
to talk he wanted to help the student
work out his own problems talk for Dewey
was the transactional version of
thinking talking together listening
together thinking together the casual
observer might conclude that Dewey's
manner of thinking as teaching might
simply have been a natural derivative of
his gentle and abstracted personality
but we have evidence first city was
hardly gentle and some of his combative
periods but we have evidence that he had
consciously decided to teach by exposing
as one of his book titles put it how we
think more precisely how he thought and
how his students might come to think one
party of evidence of the deliberate
deliberate intentions behind his manner
are the notes for his lectures that
survived the usual procedure of being
crumbled and tourist orphan and I have
some of those notes often they're
extremely detailed and explicitly state
the problem to be considered during the
hour indicating what was problematic and
why a method of investigation generally
follows in these notes and objections to
his method then the problem might be
stated in a different light which might
lead to hypotheses questions and warrant
herbal assertions or provisional
conclusions examples of evidence come
next a new problem would arise and a
conclusion until the next class would be
tentatively reached but he suggested a
list of readings also to encourage
through the thought until the next class
meeting these No
were all for himself and then they
disappeared of course in the class the
second piece of evidence that do his
teaching manner was well thought out
comes from the experience of those who
heard him lecture as both a professor
and as a political speaker as a teacher
Bruce Ralph says Joey was in a world of
thought but Ralph also happened upon
Dewey as he gave a speech on behalf of
Robert La Follette during the senatorial
campaign of his campaign for president
in 1924 I was never so surprised in my
life at anybody as I was at doing at
that meaning came time for him to speak
and he was the principal speaker at the
meeting he stood on the speaker's stand
and revealed revealed the man in a
different perspective in a in a
different manner from that which I had
become acquainted with in the classroom
he spoke with wit he spoke fluidly
rapidly not slow a deliberate he spoke
with zest and zeal for the cause and
simply held the audience spellbound well
that was a Dewey I had never seen before
teaching was thinking and required the
manner of reflection a political speaker
performed an act that was meant to lead
to a vote or an action it required the
manner of an act of transaction advising
was aimed at understanding and in that
Dewey's manner was empathetic curiosity
his philosophic articles and books his
political journalism his engagements in
social controversy and his essays on
literature or not or required different
appropriate treatments do his version of
Sullivan's dictum that form follows
function to his teaching was central to
his life as writing was and moreover
gave during the experience of listeners
that he carried over into his best
writing talking or teaching increasingly
became the source of his publications
from Morris's book on Hegel's philosophy
of the state and his Hopkins classes
with Herbert backs to Adams do we absorb
the conviction that the job of the
philosopher was to think about society
and politics as a political philosophy
doing never exhibited much interest or
enthusiasm for the so-called left to
galleons David Strauss feuerbach
contrariwise he was deeply influenced by
the parallel stream in Hegel's thought
to which Hegel himself gave preference
that it's so cold right a galleon ISM
Morris and through Mars to Dewey
showed the strong influence of the
writer galleons especially those in
England Thomas Hill Greene Edward card
and in logic but not vos and Kent while
stressed the ideal of the universal self
and advancing freedom which in politics
means social analysis leading to
democracy American politics at Hopkins
Woodrow Wilson absorbed the same
influence as can be seen in his goal of
saving democracy for mankind and in his
derivative program at Versailles of 14
points not surprisingly then even as
Dewey was improving upon Hall's
psychological lead in his psychology and
several psychological essays he began to
follow at Martha's commitment to examine
society in politics with the same aim of
evolving freedom and bolstering
democracy in 1986 same year of
psychology as published we find him
quote reading up on machinery and wages
studying Samuel Tilden's political
speeches and read and quote a number of
French and German histories of the
laboring classes he was doing this
research because he was preparing at
this time for a talk to be given to the
American Political Science Association
its subject would be the rise of great
industries in his talk he spoke with
passion on the degradation of democracy
through rampant industrial development a
report of the speech class stood as a
masterly study of the economic
industrial social and moral effects of
the great corporate undertakings of
modern times but though there had been
abuse Dewey declared the future is still
full of hope for all classes in a
recasting of this talk two years later
he wrote democracy is not in reality
what it is a name
until it is industrial as well as not
only industrial but also civil and
political workers have the right he told
the rather conservative members of the
PSA to organize trade unions in order to
read democratize the industrial system
Dewey's interest in democracy and its
vicissitudes was deepening he followed
his critique of the great industries
with the talk of the to the philosophic
society anza Henry mains conception of
democracy in which he used mains
critique of democracy to present his own
much more positive view that democracy
approaches in here Hegel brighter
galleon ISM but democracy approaches
most nearly the ideal of all social
organization that in which the
individual and society are organic to
each other few months later he spoke
more pointedly in a talk at an arbor in
delphi hall asserting that the aim of
the educated man should be to keep in
sympathy with the people and he'd be
weld the increase in economic class
thinking in america i do not need to
remind such an audience as this of the
way in which from this germ duly became
the leading political philosopher of his
time the historian Henry Steele comander
remarked that no political question in
America was settled until Dewey had
spoken on it during his life from Morris
green mill Cod and the others do he took
the belief that freedom freedom of
inquiry and philosophy and freedom
meaning democracy and government was
central in man's nature and thus in
man's ideals of the concepts with which
Dewey was most preoccupied as at think
if democracy was certainly one of the
most important do we know that democracy
was fragile stronger as a critique of
other political and social systems than
it was of its own operations do we made
a profound shift which we have not yet
begun to absorb in understanding
democracy not as a political system or a
body of Rights or an excrescence of such
documents as the Declaration of indepen
or the Constitution or as a system of
legislation or legal authorities but as
a way of life
he was explicit about this in democracy
and educational administration an essay
of 1937 he wrote the key note of
democracy as a way of life may be
expressed it seems to me as the
necessity for the participation of every
mature human being in formation of the
values that regulate the living of men
together formation is the key word in
this idea that democracy is a way of
life
democracy consists in the formation of
values not in pre-established values we
do not hold to democratic values we
experimental II strive toward them and
then live them James Gulen Locke rightly
says that do he created the most
innovative and elaborately developed
philosophy of value to appear in modern
history value for Dewey always meant
something correlative to freedom and
freedom takes courage after his last
public appearance Ernest Nagel
remembered that his advice this is Nagel
to the young men and women graduate
students in his audience was you must
have the courage to try new ideas he
made clear his conviction that while
learning is fine and important learning
is not a substitute for the great
adventure of exposing ideas and
developing them he was speaking Nagel
says from the heart he was not
recommending himself this is me not
Nagel now as a hero as suggesting that
he be imitated he was saying that all of
us should live our lives to the full not
in the shadow of the thoughts of others
except as we make these our own in
advance beyond them in a quite Amazonian
way do he was saying is the quote
Socrates or Washington or Raphael or
Beethoven or Sir Isaac Newton what do
you only what they can reveal of your
own capacity and circumstance to
yourself his courage resided in the
optimism for which Dewey has often been
mocked skepticism without optimism
is fashionable and always easy optimism
takes courage hard work to sustain in
the face face of a world that is always
brutal but it has a necessary function
in the continuation of culture President
Lyndon Johnson said as much to James T
Farrow
the novelist when he remarked for myself
this is Johnson I find a deep and
lasting significance in dr. Johnnie's
belief that the greatest sin of all is
to lose faith in one's fellow man
Johnson took the phrase a great society
from Dewey's book the public and its
problems but perhaps the greatest
dimension of Dewey's courage was singled
out by Clifford Geertz reflecting on
what above all else he had learned from
Dewey Geertz arrived at the chilling
conclusion that thought is conduct and
is to be judged as such the reason
thinking is so serious is that it is a
social act and that one is therefore
responsible for it as for any other
social act perhaps even more so for in
the long run it is the most
consequential of social acts in short it
says
Dewey brings thinking into the public
world where ethical judgment can get at
it yes was pointing to the reason why do
his work on ethics and valuation is so
valuable its strength is its rigor and
asserting the moral relation of the
individual to the social world
Dewey's was the sort of courage that
must remain a residue in contemporary
culture because there are so few sources
of such moral clarity in our own time
and we need remind us of what courage
can be and mean in intellectual life as
well as social life to a turbid Mead
Express the value and the difficulties
of Dewey's pragmatism in remarking it is
a philosophy which comes with something
of the effect of a cold shower and it
depends somewhat upon the vitality of
the man whether it leaves him with a
chill or a glow near the end of his life
a student of Dewey's remembered he spoke
at Columbia and when the applause died
down he got up not to take a bow but to
add something a word of caution
to be a philosopher takes guts he said
to be a philosopher does take guts I
virtually need a lot of today so do he
himself had the courage to bring his
life into his philosophy and his
philosophy into his life you all know
how he did this in his books the public
and its problems individualism old and
new liberalism and social action as well
as dozens of essays and innumerable
speeches on public policy and public
production time after time in his life
he gave himself to the liberal cause of
freedom at the risk of his new position
at the University of Chicago he
supported Eugene Debs and the strikers
at Pullman when maxim gorky they came to
New York shortly after Dewey arrived at
Columbia and it was discovered that the
woman with him Madame andreyeva was his
mistress and not his wife all liberals
shunned him mocked Wayne William Dean
Howells and President Theodore Roosevelt
refused to meet with him no hotel would
take him in but Dewey invited Gorky and
Madame Andrey Eva into his apartment and
arranged receptions for them he spent
two and a half years lecturing in Japan
and China in order to promote the
burgeoning democracies there and to
teach democratic values in the new
culture movement in China he marched in
protests at a time when it took courage
to do so in contrast today when it may
take courage not to do so when teachers
were fired at colleges and even high
schools in the shadow of the First World
War
do we publicly spoke out in their
support he did the same in 1940 when
Bertrand Russell was threatened with
dismissal from his conduct from his
contract at City College
an advanced age fairly rapidly after
Russell had criticized him also many
times do he had also nursed Russell and
China back to health and even made its
last will and testament for only Russell
recovered to criticize doing
when the issues of civil rights arose he
helped to found the NAACP
despite death threats and the loss of
many liberal friends at 72 years old he
chaired the hearings in Mexico City into
the accusations made by Yosef Starling
against Leon Trotsky if liberals will
like you Trotsky dogmatic Marxist said
at the end of the hearings I would
become a liberal doubtless Dewey would
be best remembered for his political
activity in the aftermath of the stock
market crash and during the New Deal it
was occasionally invited to the White
House and ate their meals and drank
their drinks but never agreed with the
White House very much he became the
first president of the lake for
independent political action he was
asked to be the gubernatorial candidate
for the Socialist party's ticket in New
York in 1930 he became the first
president of the People's Lobby he was
president of the League for industrial
democracy he was the chairman of the
United action Campaign Committee whose
aim was quote to get down into the dirt
and dust of the political arena and
fight for human rights in a practical
aggressive realistic manner
ever since Morton White's social thought
in America the result revolt against
formalism was published in 1957
following in the tradition of Randolph
borns attack on Dewey in 1918 Dewey has
been occasionally charged with offering
philosophic critiques of American
politics without supplying concrete
proposals for reform it's White's theme
as white sword Dewey supplied quote no
particular or a specific political
position that can be acted upon only a
plea for intelligence but white was
wrong the astonishing number of
political proposals that do we made and
work for during the depression shows how
involved he was in promulgating actual
policies that he believed would
ameliorate suffering and enhance social
justice it's going to get a catalog now
Dewey and not America beginning in 1929
Dewey proposed and argued for
one a federally planned economy
involving government control or
ownership of Natural Resources utilities
power coal banking railroads and credit
to regulation of the radio and press
three the taxation of unearned
increments in land value for higher
taxes for higher income brackets five
the calling of special sessions of
Congress to ensure more continuous and
more effective government planning to
meet people's needs six unemployment
insurance seven massive outlays for
public works eight a four-year
presidential plan to spend at least five
million dollars for public works and 250
million for direct relief nine taxes on
corporations ten taxes on inheritance
eleven worker's insurance twelve old-age
pensions thirteen the abolition of child
labor 14 a six-day Work day a six-hour
workday 15 aid to farmers including a
reduction in tariffs 16 recognition of
the Soviet Union and 17 participation in
the world Court we live today of course
in a world that do we recommended that
before the New Deal got to it and before
we've gotten to all these things
Charlson dispersed was the last of the
Hopkins mentors that do we arrived at
and I take him up last here do his book
logic the theory of inquiry' 1938
completed when Dewey was 79 years old as
one of his best books perhaps his best
part of its inside narrative is Dewey's
lifelong dialogue with Perce as early as
1893 do expressed his opposition to a
central idea held by pers concerning
necessary truths James doing realized
had adapted Pierce's purses idea in his
principles of psychology grounding the
psychology of that book in the
subjective experience of truths a priori
to experience for all of his admiration
for James's book Dewey could not be
satisfied with the assumption of a
mental structure incorporating necessary
Truths nor could he accept purses
transcendental argument for a priori
truths in his essay the superstition of
necessity duly articulated the
conviction that would rule his
philosophic method up to and beyond the
logic of 1938 philosophies he asserted
could easily fall into the superstition
of quote clinging to old ideas after
those ideas have lost their use and
hence like all superstitions have become
obstruction by seeming to be necessary
truths the idea of necessity of
necessary truths which Purse had
defended in his 1893 essay the doctrine
of necessity examined was one of those
superstitions due he believed do we
modestly wrote that his own thought
would take a different turn from purses
to his turn was experimental psychology
when we say something or other must be
so he wrote the must does not indicate
anything in the nature of the fact
itself but a trade in our judgment of
the fact necessity is simply a stage of
thought one of the tools of inquiry into
the object of investigation its
character Dewey Road is purely
teleological and practical necessity is
neither accidental nor necessary but a
logical construction a sort of as if
proposition that functions to produce
judgments about reality and activity in
it is one part of the usable instruments
of logic that we employ in grappling
with experience do we separate himself
quietly from this basic underpinning of
James's principles of psychology and he
also just as quietly rejected some of
purses other moves starting in 1887
which concluded in purses acceptance of
necessary transcendental truths that are
intrinsic in the cosmic order do we
simultaneously rejected the subjectivist
move in James and purses objective
idealism and began the logical process
that would lead to his own instrumental
naturalism do we distinguish between the
logical function and meaning of
necessity
fallacy of the necessity rien theory
consists he wrote in transforming the
determinant sense of the wholly defined
into the determinate in the sense of
something made to be what it is in
studies and logical theory Dewey went
further he provided for James Ian's
pragmatism the kind of logic the logic
of use that would dispose entirely of
James's superstition of necessity do we
did not need to point this out to James
for James thereafter accepted Dewey's
logic and Method completely and thus had
no more need to assume necessary truths
purse reacted very differently to do his
criticism and reservations in public in
a review in the nation he praised Dewey
studies and he publicly said I always
devote myself to developing originality
in my pupils and I'm never better
pleased than when they attacked my
position but in private he was obviously
stung by his former students attack on
his transcendental objective idealism it
must have heard to that the centerpiece
of Dewey's criticism was his employment
against purse of the very same logical
tools that purse had given him in his
early article the fixation of belief so
it's not surprising that purse struck
out in Dewey in a private letter purse
wrote your style of reasoning about
reasoning has to my mind the usual fault
that often men touch on this subject
they seem to think that no reasoning can
be too loose but indeed there is a merit
in such slipshod arguments they as they
themselves would not dream of using in
any other branch of science Dewey and
his University of Chicago students per
said had given themselves over to a
debauch of loose reasoning well we're
still intellectual licentiousness only
three sciences provide logic with
principles purse maintain mathematics
phenomenology and ethics in particular
he completely derided the value of
psychology which Dewey had employed to
reject versus necessity anism merely
circular or tautological
humans purse wrote and could say that
with logic about the psychology book
come from metaphysical philosophy
psychology linguistics or history and it
sort of PostScript of written along the
centerfold of this letter purse came
down like a hammer on one of Dewey
central assumptions in studies the idea
the two such elements as evolution and
function can in the same sense depend
upon one another seems to be absurd
underlined underlined and delight still
purse concluded somewhat easing his
rebuke of his little student he would
not write as he had done to any man with
whom I did not feel a deep respect and
sympathy Dewey was attacked many times
in his life and never did fur deterred
by any attacks and so he kept reading
purse in 1931 when Paul vice was Weis
was preparing a biographical article on
Percy wrote to Dewey who admitted he had
not been prepared at the time he was at
Hopkins either by bind dominant interest
or previous training to appreciate the
significance of his work I could see he
was a very learned at an original man
but I never got further than that by
1932 when Dewey began reviewing purses
collected papers as they appeared purse
was doing now claim the most original
philosopher philosophic pine this
country has produced in logical theory
both in its traditional form as a theory
of scientific method and a modern
symbolic logic he was a philosophers
philosopher in 1935 when the fifth
volume of the collected papers dealing
with pragmatism appeared do we reviewed
it this volume Dewey advised should be
obligatory for all philosophers this was
a generous assessment for by the time
Dewey had gone beyond purse and found
his own way in logical analysis purses
ideas due he maintained augmented his
own a little lot in the way of
confirmation and gain and distance to
purse denying persistent central
influence
do it certainly worked out his own
logical theory by 1901 to 13 before he
seriously began studying purse but the
confirmation that came through purse was
important and eventually led to Dewey's
logic a theory of inquiry so at last an
old man due he completed the circle of
influences offered him by his hopkins
professors maras hall purse each of
aided him in the discovery of his own
aims and destiny as a philosopher
different as they were they all fused in
Dewey and helped to make him what he
would be I am mindful that in pursuing
these biographical reflections on
philosophy Dewey's philosophy before an
audience consisting in some part of
faculty and students I have perhaps
raised in the minds of the first faculty
what legacy am i conferring to my
students and in the second how might the
influences I am experiencing now here at
Hopkins how might they turn me in quite
unsuspected directions after I leave
here perhaps decades later perhaps for
all my life if by examining Dewey's life
and philosophy I've raised these
questions it is what I intended to do
for every good lecture I hope you will
think this at least in part one most
must eventually bring you back to
yourself
Dewey died 50 years ago but like Walt
Whitman at the end of song of myself
he stopped somewhere waiting for you to
discover what you can learn from his
philosophy and from his life thank you
okay will you take some questions yes if
there ones I could answer to dismiss the
group I already warned you of that so
you have to ask me simple questions are
there any and comments of course
comments of betta because then I can
admire them and experience the lecture
as it goes on into the transactional
knowing of our community here when
questions are never simple so try to ask
but temporary dialogues between French
and Americans perspectives and I was
reminded of one here at Hopkins some
years back which brought over a group of
people identified he's what French then
called
Sciences of man and something of the
gospel as well our emerging group of
sects you're related to structure
awesome there was an American side to
this although if one looks at the
printed records one finds that the
French visitors occupy dimensional
larger place into all this this is
probably the fact
burdened the tapes but I was struck when
a number of the French visitors arrived
they began to instruct those of us who
were here at Hopkins who included people
had come in from elsewhere about the
heritage of Charles senators purse and
this was a little like the French Freud
I mean required yes
relearning the proceedings went on for a
week and various are risky vows and so
forth but in the course of this there
were some people engaged on the American
side who were of a certain age one was a
teacher of the church Boas and he had
suggested that we invite a former
teacher of hits now this was a stretch
because George was then I suppose in his
late 70s and he suggested Jacqueline
Burke who of course the Connection we
saw was with Joran believed was talking
about practicing phenomenology and it
turned out they had known each other
over the years Loewenberg was probably
about 1993 at this point very alert
slightly deaf he left a little arrow I
didn't stay through the whole week
because he had tickets to go to some
shows that were opening to New York and
I thought that was a heroic way to deal
very long symposia but the interesting
thing was the to me was as the week
progressed these two very elderly folks
George Louis and Jack von Berg must came
over and said you know
all this business about structuralism it
really is doing it's doing it's doing
and we had a couple of discussions I
said well engage our friends well it
turned out our French friends of course
is not the number who were philosophers
but they do do it really oh yes say a
chapter in American history someone
liked if not sellers are involved or
somebody's they do a lot more about the
development of American philosophy but
their questions frequently were well
what was his relationship to person
you've now given an answer which I
didn't have readily available at the
time whatever it was 40 years ago this
group was convenes I think that that
clearly is not a question and I guess
the only question I ask is that probably
if you were to speculate what was in
duties they have lost the station I
think probably one of his published
essays gives us a pretty good idea but
my question is what do you imagine the
dissertation consistent in psychology he
he wrote to WT Harris that Harris had
been the originator of his idea that
Harris had dropped a casual remark when
due he was an undergraduate still that
he had read in the Journal of
speculative philosophy saying that the
great psychological movement was from in
philosophy was through Conte
to Hegel - he said he had no idea what
that meant because he hadn't read Hegel
yet but once he did read Hegel with Mars
then then he was able to see the
psychological movement that content
introduced that Hegel had followed so my
impression is from that letter that
that's as close as he got there is of
course and published commentary that may
be similar to what is
and that in an essay as you say after
his dissertation was completed but but
that letter for me
tells even a bit more yeah that that the
sense that of Conte as hovering as Dewey
would then have seen it upon a momentous
kind of discovery that then Hegel was
simply able to use in terms of the
psychology now then later on of course
when do we wrote German philosophy and
politics is very hard on Conte and in
some sense
he did he always was influenced by Conte
I think but left Conte behind as a as an
instrument for philosophic logic his
argument there was of course as he saw
it in the German people not in con but
as the German people received conned
that can't split the German
consciousness between private morality
and obedience to the state and that led
to the first world war and the the kind
of split between civilization and
Barbary as it were and and he traced
that back to Kant not as can't put it
but his cut was received by his public
but but the the comment that professor
Maxie made allows me to also reflect a
little bit on the French French doing
one of the most touching and all the in
all of the pieces manuscripts and
Diaries and letters I wrote was an
account when doing received an honorary
doctorate in Paris in the University of
Paris in 1930 he also as usually he was
a good work and he prepared a lecture
for the philosophy department and and
delivered it to the department on the
occasion of his getting a doctorate at
the end of his lecture the first person
who stood up and that it that in a way
this ended the commentary was Marcel
Mauss and he's
and he stood up I'm reading this in you
know manuscript from long ago but it
came alive for me
he stood up with tears running down his
eyes and in his cheeks and so on and he
said my my great mentor emailed Durkheim
gave his last lecture on the philosophy
philosophy he had arrived at as the
philosopher of modern time the one that
he would look to write before he died
this was John Dewey and he said I have a
few myself master I have a few little
note cards from that lecture and these I
treasure beyond all else and now to be
able to say this to John Dewey is all
that I ever wanted to do sat down sat
down that was he had no more questions
no more comments nobody else could cry
so well yeah I don't know about I really
I confess I don't know about the of the
French purse I have a suspicion that the
French purse must be like the French PO
somewhat different
what on earth do his teachers are indeed
doing himself thought they saw income I
mean the way Kant would be taught today
yes would be that he actually made a
decisive distinction between philosophy
and empirical psychology I mean more or
less right at the beginning of critique
of pure reason when he says Locke ask
the question quit bhakti yes it's like a
lots of a question where do ideas come
from but the question philosophy is quit
Duras by what right do we use them and
that can't be answered in a
psychological way at all so I find it
kind of odd to think that Dewey thought
by reading Kant you know this showed
that philosophy was really psychology
yeah and it seems to me that it had a
profound effect this initial decision
because
it connected a deep way I think with
with Dewey's almost total eclipse in
contemporary academic philosophy because
almost at the same time as Dewey is
writing a book saying we really should
be doing psychology yeah
Prager is announcing the repudiation of
psychologism as incapable of accounting
for validity in mathematics and
inventing modern mathematical logic in
the course of it and her soul of course
reached Rhaegar and the scales fall from
his eyes and so phenomenology takes in
in continental European philosophy takes
a decisively non psychological turn and
so both what would become analytic
philosophy in the Anglophone world and
phenomenological for philosophy on the
continent the two movies in the way
would dominate the 20th century mm-hm
take their repudiation of psychologism
as if do you really sort of missed them
both on day one you know I mean but and
and of course by fossil personality
makes this great career in America and
there's some how when he goes the
landscape changes all around in a way
that even his ghost finds it hard to
hold the Jade's laugh anyway so I mean I
thought this this was a fascinating
story that you had to tell it did make
me wonder what on earth they thought
they were reading in Cannes I mean the
big
today well thanks for doing them Kant
was part of his this is this is a Dewey
at this point after all just finishing
in graduate studies eighteen eighteen
eighty six very divided and with with
his interest going in all directions I
think finally for Kant can't
fed into Dewey's early interest in
ethics and the rest of [ __ ] he he
interpreted through ethics and made a
psychological leap from ethics to
psychological theory made Conte what he
wanted to make him in that sense but I
think the condo is chiefly important for
doing as an ethical thinking do you know
not thought of so much today his book
with Tufts in 1908 on ethics and then
revised in 1932 in America you think of
America at the time in the eighteen
seventies eighties what was happening
the the idea of you could see it earlier
with Emerson and so on the idea that God
somehow in the Bible were going to give
authority to ethical considerations was
declining and so the Americans clergymen
thinkers people in general looking
around for well what would be the source
to maintain the importance of
Christianity and it would become an
ethical source so this is a social
cultural phenomena that's occurring
there and Hegel for the same reason the
great sort of hegelian movement among
Christians is to say idealism can be
sustained without superfluous
investigation of of God and of the Bible
so I think that that's what was
happening and that's what made it and
probably frankly I think always makes it
able for people in any given time even
in our own to find what we want in a
figure well later on we may be able to
look back and say well he shouldn't have
just that if he had understood it
completely he he would have known that
he was on the wrong path but you take a
figure and and you find in him what's
usable for you for your time and for
yourself in the crisis either personal
or cultural at that time so I think
that's what happened with doing in
context the susceptible concept is pure
practical reason after all not I mean
yeah I mean can't sees himself as
repudiating psychologist with ethics
which you would see in the English
sentimentalist or something in favor of
something but so I just might do he's
taking extremely strange again the
repudiation of the psychologism it sort
of pushed aside I think by people at
that time by toughs as well but lots of
people George Herbert Palma whoever you
think of in in the Harvard group or
elsewhere and is the stress upon
Christianity divinity is reasonable is
what they take from it and I think
probably even with Marsh earlier this is
in the 1830s after all as beginning to
look at can't wash says rights to samuel
taylor coleridge helped me a little bit
with the ad aesthetic cut you seem to
understand him and basically what he was
looking for was a and quote aid to
reflection that would lead him to be
able to defend Christianity from a
different point of view
yeah from the point of view of logic and
Christianity becomes rational and ideal
a speculation yes he wouldn't think
about it as to whether or not when you
work
the central argument of his first book
psychology the way it struck my ears is
that it was the very argument that one
uses in the introductory chapters that
he's laying as the philosophical
foundation for a scientific psychology
but it's just that argument that's what
struck me as you were as you were
characterizing that and we're Stanley
Hall as someone who studied with voting
so did we have an effects of it he's
taking an argument that has an origin
and one's writing but see now God's
transcendental psychology through that
kind of lens and so you can about with
this idea that psychology is the
fundamental science and so that from
Hegel beyond cut so so Hegel comes into
that mix I think it's exactly right now
now I've forgotten the date of elements
book the reason is the date I don't want
to falsify anything in favor of doing
but my impression is that once book is a
year after doings yeah
Wood did not read do you I'm sure it's
okay so we can't say that yeah yeah we
can't say what got this for Dewey it
might be nice if we could say that but I
think no but I think it's a year after I
think it's 1887 but but Hall of course
had already gotten what Wood was doing
and when Hall arrived at Hopkins it was
in 1884 so this is you'd been teaching a
little bit at how of it before there and
and Hall had the the separate idea that
education and the school would become
the greatest laboratory and place to
study psychology and to defend it as an
empirical science that's not invent but
as I think but characteristically given
the crisis of American education at that
time in the 1880s where American
now after the Kalamazoo decision a high
school had to be paid for by the state
it was no longer optional students could
be if they wanted to go to high school
it would have to be supported by the
state nobody knew what to make high
school to be exactly and so the idea was
let's make it a laboratory and of course
to his laboratory school it's Chicago I
just ramble on to one other thing I mean
Dewey is often of course accused of
having created all of the abuses in
public school education but really when
he finished at Chicago and went to
Columbia in 1904 that was the end of his
work in in education he wrote some
reflective books on education and
culture education and democracy and so
on but he did no more laboratory work
well that's the problem that the person
with of course Fitzpatrick was an
important supporter of Dewey but the
great teacher of of Teachers College in
Columbia and the great teacher who
replaced Dewey judge in Chicago both
anti Dewey Judd got rid of all of the
all of the philosophies that do we have
involved in the education department
changed all the requirements and the
courses and so on and Thorndike who
directed three or four hundred
dissertations and students was far from
a Dewey I at all so Judd and Thorndike
were probably the persons most
responsible for the school system that
we got in the 1920s 30s and it's still
sort of lingers on yeah yeah not doing
unfortunately so I this is not
responsive this part to what you said
but it's be interesting to ask now with
the again renewal of a sense of the
necessity for reform in education is was
there anything in Dewey's approach to
education that was that long ago let go
in nineteen
for that might be useful now his
laboratory school no required every day
for the faculty assessing every student
and how he learned and every day having
every student tell if he learned
everything anything and how he did it
or how he thought he had done it so it
was truly a laboratory school this we're
not doing that anymore you have been a
wonderful audience I thank you very much
J Martin is currently a humanities
professor at Claremont McKenna College
the education of John Dewey is published
by Columbia University Press visit
Columbia dot edu slash Cu slash CU p for
more information next week on public
lives wheels for the world a biography
of automobile manufacturer henry ford